this video is about the weighted Cohen's
Kappa you will learn when to use it how
to calculate it and what the difference
between linear and quadratic weighting
is
what do you use the Cohen's Kappa for
you use the Cohen's Kappa whenever you
want to know if two people's
measurements agree these two people
measuring something are called ratus
in the case of the normal cornskapper
the variable to be measured by the two
Radars is a nominal variable with a
nominal variable the Expressions can be
distinguished but there's no ranking
between the expressions
the Cohen's Kappa takes into account
whether or not the two Raiders measured
the same thing but it does not take into
account the degree of this agreement now
what if you don't have a nominal
variable but an ordinal one
if you have an ordinal variable a
variable in which the values can be
ordered then of course you want to take
this order into account let's say your
expressions are dissatisfied neutral and
satisfied there is a smaller difference
between satisfied and neutral than
between dissatisfied and satisfied if
you want to take the size of the
difference into account you have to use
the weighted Cohen's Kappa therefore if
you have a nominal variable you use
Cohen's Kappa if it is an ordinal
variable you use the weighted Cohen's
Kappa with this we can now State the
weighted coins Capper is a measure of
the agreement between two ordinelli
scale samples it is important to note
that with Cohen's Capper you can only
make a statement about how reliably both
both Raiders measure the same thing but
you cannot make a statement about
whether what the two greatest measure is
the right thing or not so if both raters
almost always measure the same your
Cohen's Kappa would be very high the
cone's Kappa does not tell you whether
this measured value matches reality for
example whether the right thing is being
measured in the first case one speaks of
the reliability and in the second case
one speaks of the validity now of course
the question arises how is Cohen's Kappa
calculated well the answer is quite
simple you can either simply use stata
tab and calculate the weighted Kappa
online or the second way is you can
calculate it by hand and we will now go
through both ways first I'll show you
which form less you need for the
weighted coins Capper and we'll go
through these formulas with an example
then I will show you how you can easily
calculate the weighted coins Kappa
online with data tab let's assume two
doctors rated how satisfied they are
with the success of the patient's
therapy the doctors can answer with
dissatisfied neutral and satisfied now
you want to know how big the agreement
between the two doctors is since we have
an ordinal variable here with the rank
order dissatisfied neutral and satisfied
we determine the agreement with the
weighted currents Kappa in the first
case we create a table with the
frequencies of each response here we
have our two raters each of whom rated
one person let's say a total of 75
patients were evaluated now let's count
how many times each combination occurs
let's say 17 times both raters answered
dissatisfied eight times greater 1
answer dissatisfied and rated 2 answered
neutral then we have four times that
greater 1 answer dissatisfied and rate
the two answer satisfied and so on and
so forth for the ratings that lie on the
diagonal both Raiders agree so what is
the formula now for the weighted Cohen's
Kappa well the way that Cohen's Kappa
can be calculated with this formula here
are the weighting factors f o are the
observed frequencies and f e are the
expected frequencies instead of the
frequencies we could also use the
calculated probabilities for example The
observed probabilities Po and the
expected probabilities PE we've just
calculated the observed frequencies you
can see them in this table if we would
not use the frequencies but the
probabilities we would simply divide
each frequency by the number of patients
so for example 75 then we would have the
observed probabilities but now we need
the weights and the expected frequencies
let's start with the expected
frequencies to calculate the expected
frequencies we first calculate the rows
and the columns sums so we just sum up
all the rows and all the columns for
example in the first row we get a sum of
29 with 17 plus 8 plus 4. now we divide
this by 75 our total number of cases
next we can calculate the expected
frequencies for each cell by multiplying
the row probability by the column
probability so for the first cell we get
0.35 times
0.39 which is equal to
0.13 for the second cell
0.44 times 0.39 which is equal to
0.17 if we multiply each probability by
75 we get the expected frequencies so
now we have the observed and the
expected frequencies all that is needed
now is the weighting Matrix if we did
not use any weighting at all our Matrix
would look like this if both raters
answer the same there is 0 in the cells
otherwise it would be 1. it doesn't
matter how far apart the rate is
answered if they answered something
different it will be weighted with one
but let's now look look at the linear
and the quadratic weighting the linear
weighting Matrix can be calculated with
this formula let e be the index for the
rows and J for the columns K is the
number of categories so in our case it
is three so for the first cell we get 1
minus 1 divided by 2 which is equal to
zero for this cell we get 2 minus 1
divided by 2 which is equal to 0.5 and
finally for that cell we get 3 minus 1
divided by 2 which is equal to one we
can now do this for all other cells and
we get this weighting Matrix this means
that ratings that are close to one
another are weighted less than ratings
that are far apart how does it look now
with the quadratic weighting if we do
not use the linear but quadratic waiting
the distances are simply squared again
this means that scores that are far
apart awaited even more heavily in
relation to scores that are close
together compared to the linear case the
weighting Matrix then results in this
Matrix so this Cell results for example
with 2 minus 1 squared divided by 3
minus 1 squared which is equal to
0.25 so with this we can now decide
whether to use waiting or not and
whether to use the linear weighting or
the quadratic weighting we will simply
continue with the linear weighting now
so with this we can now calculate the
weighted Kappa we have the weighting
Matrix The observed frequency and the
expected frequency let's start with the
sum up here we simply multiply each cell
of the weighting matrix by the
respective cell of The observed
frequency and sum this up so for example
0 times 17 plus 0.5 times 8 until
finally zero times nine we just do the
same with the weighting Matrix and the
expected frequency zero times
10.05 plus 0.5 times
12.76 until finally zero times
3.84 now if we do all the calculations
this gives us a weighting Capper of
0.396 and finally I'll show you how you
can easily calculate the weighted
Cohen's Capper for your data online with
data tab in order to do this you simply
we go to datadeep.net and copy your own
data into this table now you click on
the reliability tab data tab
automatically tries to assign a scale
level to your data in this case datadab
assumes that it is nominal data if we
would click on rater 1 and Raider 2 Data
tab would calculate the unweighted
normal Cohen's Kappa but in our case
these are ordinal variables so we simply
change the scale level to ordinal
if we now click on both Raiders the
weighted currents Capper is calculated
we can now choose whether we want to
have a linear or a gradratic weighting
here we can see the cross table which
shows us how often the respective
combinations occur then we get the
results for the Cohen's Kappa with this
data we get a weighted coins cap of 0.5
if you're not sure how to interpret the
results you can just click on summary in
words an integrate a reliability
analysis was performed between the
dependent samples of rater 1 and rater
2. for this purpose the weighted coins
Capital was calculated which is a
measure of the agreement between two
dependent ordinal scale samples the
weighted coinscapper showed that there
was a moderate agreement between samples
rate 1 and rated 2 with k equals 0.5
thanks for listening and I hope to see
you soon